PRESIDENT'S RALLY THROUGHOUT THE
HOUR, BUT FIRST MY OPEN.
WE NOW ENTER A NEW PHASE OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
AMIDST THE OUTRAGEOUS,
OUTLANDISH LEFT-WING CHAOTIC MOB
BEHAVIOR OF SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS.
AMERICAN MOMENTUM IS NOW AROUND
WINNING.
THE WINNING THAT OUTSIDER
CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP PROMISED
US.
NOT THE ANARCHY DEMOCRATS, AKA
DEMON RATS WANT TO IMPOSE ON US.
THESE THE TACTICS OF THESE DEMON
RATS AND TRUMP-HATING LEFTISTS
ARE BACKFIRING.
AMERICANS ARE NOW BUYING INTO
AND CHOOSING RESULTS OVER
POLITICALLY CORRECT LOSING
BEHAVIOR OF OTHER PRESIDENTS.
WHEN THE "NEW YORK TIMES," BRET
STEVENS, AND THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL'S" PEGGY NOONIAN SAID
SENATE DEMOCRATS OVERPLAY THEIR
HAND AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
BLOWING IT, YOU KNOW THEY SENSE
WHAT'S COMING.
AND IT'S NOT THE BLUE WAVE THE
GENIUS PUNDITS PREDICTED.
THEY KNOW THEY LOST THE
KAVANAUGH FIGHT AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ALONG THE WAY.
AMERICANS DON'T LIKE LIES,
INJUSTICE, AND THEY DON'T LIKE
VIGILANTE OR MOB JUSTICE.
THE INSANITY WE WITNESSES FROM
THOSE SUFFERING FROM TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME IS SHOCK
AND UNPRECEDENTED.
FROM BEING TOSSED OUT OF
RESTAURANTS TO BEING DIRECTED TO
HARASS, INTIMIDATE, CONFRONT AND
MAKE A CROWD AROUND ANYONE THEY
DON'T AGREE WITH, THEY RAMPED IT
UP EVEN MORE DURING THE
KAVANAUGH HEARINGS.
SCREAMING, INTERRUPTING,
SHOUTING DOWN SENATORS, BLOCK
THEM FROM VOTING.
AND THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO BLOCK
THEM FROM VOTING AND IN THEIR
FEIGNED LOSER OUTRAGE, THEY CLAW
ON THE DOORS OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT AS
KAVANAUGH IS BEING SWORN IN.
AMERICANS ARE FAIR, AND THEY
HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
ACCORDING TO REAL CLEAR
POLITICS, REPUBLICAN SENATORS IN
KEY STATES HAVE DRAMATICALLY
TURNED THINGS AROUND.
CRUZ, BLACKBURN, HELLER,
MCSALLY, AND DEMON RAT CORY
BOOKER WHO IS NOW THE
LAUGHINGSTOCK OF THE SENATE
AFTER LIKENING HIMSELF TO
SPARTACUS FELL FLAT OFF HIS
CHARIOT.
AND THEY JUSTIFY THEIR BEHAVIOR.
>> YOU CANNOT BE CIVIL WITH A
POLITICAL PARTY THAT WANTS TO
DESTROY WHAT YOU STAND FOR, WHAT
YOU CARE ABOUT.
JUDGE JEANINE: HILLARY, OUT OF
POWER, CASH AND HARVEY SWINE
STEIN AND YOUR OWN SEXUAL
PREDATOR HUSBAND, WHAT THE HELL
DO YOU STAND FOR.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS ONE.
>> WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE GO HIGH?
NO, NO.
WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE KICK THEM.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THAT'S WHAT THIS NEW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS ABOUT.
JUDGE JEANINE: REALLY, ERIC.
YOU A FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES CONDONE
VIOLENCE?
SOMEONE WHO THINKS BELIEFS AND
WORD JUSTIFY PHYSICAL ASSAULT?
DID YOU EVEN GO TO LAW SCHOOL?
LOOK.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
WE ARE NOT EVEN TWO YEARS INTO
TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY.
THE ECONOMY, RECORD HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT, RECORD LOW.
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP AMERICANS
SAVED $3.2 TRILLION IN TAXES.
$3.3 -- 3.3 MILLION JOBS HAVE
BEEN CREATED.
THE MILITARY IS BEING REBUILT.
120 FEDERAL JUDGES HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED.
TWO UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
A MUCH-I AM MOVED TRADE DEAL --
A MUCH-IMPROVED TRADE DEAL WITH
MEXICO AND CANADA.
80,000 ILLEGAL ALIENS HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED BY I.C.E.
15 HOSTAGES HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
HOME FROM NORTH KOREA, IRAN,
VENEZUELA AND OF COURSE JUST
TODAY, PASTOR ANDREW BRUNSON
FROM TURKEY.
SO WHO TOLD THOSE TRUMP-HATING
DEMON RATS AND THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA KEEP UP THE ANTICS.
YOU ARE ALL LOSERS.
SORE LOSERS.
STUPID LOSERS, TOO DUMB TO EVEN
KNOW YOU ARE LOSING.
HE SAID IT HIMSELF.
JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO IN
KENTUCKY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THE ONLY REASON
TO VOTE DEMOCRAT IS IF YOU ARE
TIRED OF WINNING.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]